okay um and so i brought both of these
gentlemen on the podcast
one from the standard side and the
consumer consumption side and one from
the business side in terms of
advertising to talk about the state of
podcasting in 2020
uh as many of you know i started this
podcast uh under a different name
calacanis cast 12 years ago i think and
11 years ago for this one we've done
over a thousand episodes but i think
it's a good time to pause because
there's been a lot of activity
i want to start with the big seismic
event
which marco you alluded to which was hey
this was built on open standards by a
friend of ours uh dave weiner
who led rss a really simple syndication
is that right
and then he added an attachment the
ability in your rss feed to add an
attachment that was the key moment
that enabled podcasting correct marco
yep
and ever since then it's grown and
nobody has been able to
strangle it or control it so just like
the web
just like blogs uh which actually blogs
has been kind of deprecated we'll get
into that
but the web and email and of course
podcasting have
exploded all on this open standard marco
when you saw the announcement
that joe rogan had had his show i
believe
licensed not bought for what looks like
man 50 100 million dollars for some
number of years i don't think all the
details are out
you were like f this i think on twitter
where's your quote
explain why that is so problematic to
you
and to the industry the main thing is
that podcasting
has has gotten to where it is and is as
great
and awesome as it is for all the reasons
anybody who's ever heard of rss
should already be familiar with you know
it's it's this wonderful open ecosystem
with a wide variety of producers
and consuming apps and this great
ecosystem that
isn't controlled by a single entity for
the most part you know apple's kind of
an asterisk in certain ways but for the
most part
it's not really controlled by an
individual entity and you can compare it
to something like youtube
where if you want to make video that
matters at all today
it has to be on youtube basically and so
that you have this one company's one
platform
controlling the by far like the majority
of this
really important medium and you look at
doing stuff on the web and if you do
stuff on the web you are
really beholden to facebook for traffic
and you're really beholden to google for
like for inbound search and you have
these like
these couple of massive companies that
control a massive part of
your business and and like in the case
of youtube it's even worse than the web
because you have to
do all of your business on their
platform as well and
podcasting doesn't have that right now
and it never has
apple has been the the directory of
choice
and apple still has the largest app to
consume podcasts but they have really
been
fairly benevolent in their in their
ruling of podcasts they've really taken
a very light hand to it and have
really embraced and empowered the open
ecosystem as much as they really
could uh so this one company having this
massive share hasn't
really been a problem for us and then
everybody who's not apple
is all kind of you know working in the
same ecosystem for the most part and
then the difference
is that spotify did
what a few other companies have tried to
do before and have
met with mixed success which is to kind
of create
a walled garden of podcasts that tries
to become
the default way people listen to
podcasts and
that normally wouldn't go very far but
the difference here
is that with a combination of spotify's
immense
existing market share of people
listening to music using their apps
and also an immense amount of money
they've put into it
spotify has been able to not only
acquire a pretty big chunk of market
share pretty quickly
but although it's not as big as as most
people think it is but it is still a
substantial market share
but also they've been able to now um
really put a pretty big push
of buying exclusive content for spotify
right and this is where it becomes
tricky because if you're just trying to
get listeners
then everyone's still playing on
basically the same footing everyone's
still
you know there have been a couple of
premium services before that had
exclusive content but they weren't very
big they didn't go very far
so for the most part you know an app
like overcast like my app it can
it can compete pretty easily as well as
any other app that's like over i mean
there's
hundreds of podcast apps out there and
we could all
basically play the same catalog of
content
and so it's so it's this wonderful
ecosystem of all this
creativity and all these wonderful tools
and different apps for different
preferences um
it's with a few exceptions very privacy
respective uh very
uh creator friendly it puts a lot of
control in yes
the creator's hands yes the creator gets
to
decide
hey i have this rss feed you can use it
under these rules and if you break those
rules i can restrict your access to it